>> Gord: VEGAS WILL HAVE FOUR OF
>> Ray: SHELDON KEEFE WAS
TELLING US THIS MORNING HOW MUCH
THIS LINE LOVES TO SCORE.
A  BACK TO
PIETRANGELO TO JANMARK. SPUN ANL
HAS IT.
PIERRE ENGVALL LONG REACH,
IN COMES MARNER.
KERFOOT W
A FORECHECK THAT LEADS TO A
SCORING CHANCE AND MITCH MARNER
ON THE BOARDS, BAC IT
BACK UP.
UP AHEAD FOR DAVID KAMPF.
BACK DOWN TO
>> Ray: TH PROBABLY FORTUNATE I
ONLY A 1-NOTHING AINST DETROIT ,
0-17OUR GUYS ON ONE
SIDE OF THE ICE.
AT THAT LEAEA
YOU WITH THAT?NNOR
HE SAID, I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE
IT'S MOR> Gord: AS KEEFE SAID T
MORNING, IT'S NEVER A BAD GUE
TO THE LEG OF
MATTHEWS.BUNTING
UP TOP.
NOW IT'S A THREE ON ONE.
THE FIRST THE RACE FOR
WHEN THOSE GUYS GET BACK.
>> Ray: THAT'S THEIR FIRST
CHANCE REALLY ON THISSHOOTS, FI
WIDE.
>> Gord: HE SMARNER HOLDS, BACK.
BELIEVE.
>> Gord: IMPOSSIBLE TO BELIEVE,
FROM THE EXPANSION DRAFT FOR A
FOURTH ROUND
TO COME TO THE NET AND TRY AND
GO BACK PASS THERE.
BY IN THE SLOT
LEFT TO RIGHT,
CHANCES FOR VEGASAS
PENALIZED HERE.
>> Ray: YEAH, TAVARES WAS TILL
THE PUCK STAYED OUT.
SANDIN FIRES, HEL ON THE
SATURDAY.
DETROIT IN A BACK TO BACK.
YOU SAID AT THE FRONT OFIT UP A
CAMPBELL MADE THE